dès le coup d'envoi rambouillet veut
marquer son territoire les verts mettre
plus d'intensité à l'impact et perfore
le premier rideau fontenaisiens vous
obtiennent une pénalité transformée par
camille maillot riz à la 20e minute de
jeu le même camille manioc riz profite
d'un cadrage d'école de match durant et
fils dorés
dans un stade du vieux moulin chauffé à
blanc les rambolitains envoi du jour au
large auprès tout y passe il mène
logiquement à la pause 13 heures
au retour des vestiaires l'emprise rambo
liten s'accentue au fil des minutes le
deuxième essai est un modèle de relance
de maxime kaboré le centre passe en
revue cinq joueurs font
- la transformation de l'excellent
camille maillot riz auteur d'un 4 sur 5
au pied et même à 13 contre 15 après
deux cartons blancs
les joueurs d'éric david ou sont
euphoriques la muraille rambo liten est
infranchissable
il ajoute un quatrième essai en fin de
match par l'intermédiaire de romain
bausch man score final 31 3 la montée en
division d'honneur synonyme de
championnat de france est validé pour
rambouillet peu savoure on a bien entamé
le match on a marqué deux châteaux pour
ma part j'ai concrétisé les points les
pompiers rapidement ce qui nous ce qui
nous a fait ce qui nous a mis dedans
rapidement et le plus important c'est
qu'on a été solidaires aujourd'hui mais
c'est ce qui c'est ce qui nous a tenus
on a tenu bon toute la saison comme ça
et aujourd'hui on a une équipe à
rambouillet c'est plus important